we're like yeah we're just gonna do the
same thing but a little bit cheaper and
we're calling it The Echelon it's pretty
wild that they pulled this off I saw
them originally at CES I was like oh
cool a Peloton booth and it was Echelon
it was it was the same thing it was the
exact same thing
[Music]
uh what's going on uh yeah you know lots
of things going on where do you want to
start you drive what do you got all
right I got a couple quick like random
ideas for you okay so um
so I'll call this
um
The Big Box strategy okay here's my big
box strategy so I saw recently that
Kevin Hart was like Hey are the thing
our new thing is live at Walmart
and I was like new thing what is it the
list looks pretty much like athletic
greens and sure enough it kind of is
it's just athletic greens
plus Kevin Hart
going into Walmart at like lower price
point basically how much is it athletic
craze is like 80 bucks a month yeah
athletic games is expensive uh let me
see greens let me see his thing Vita
hustle is his uh is the name of it oh my
God
um and literally it's like a picture of
him drinking his greens and electrolytes
on uh on the
on the camera or whatever so anyways I
saw going into Walmart and I had had
this realization the other day when I
was walking around at Costco I was
walking around Costco and Costco is
amazing Costco if you have a Costco deal
uh if you talk to anyone who has a
Costco deal they're like Costco drives
insane volume it will make us as a
company it also might break us as a
company because they cut like pretty
ruthless deals and if you ever like lose
Costco or they like they don't go
through with their purchase order like
you might be screwed
um but Picasso could drive a ton of
volume and I was walking around and I
basically saw in Costco if you go look
every electronic like piece of equipment
that's there is is like a
it's not a Chinese knockoff it's like an
American knockoff of an American product
yeah it's like they're light years this
mattress nine sleep it's like what this
is this is just like it's dude I have a
300 Costco mattress in one of my rooms
at my house and whenever guest stated
they go where'd you get this mattress
they ask about it all the time I'm like
[__] 280 bucks at Costco
so so basically they have a lot of these
like um
you know blenders uh you know like
fitness trackers things like that it's
they have like they need kind of like
they need it at a certain price point so
there's a strategy which is basically
you take the highly desirable thing
that's kind of at a at a too high price
point like athletic greens or another
one or a ring uh I don't know if you've
ever looked into buying an order ring
but it tracks your sleep it's whatever
it's cool ring that tracks your sleep
and it's like it's like 700 or something
like that for this ring
um and maybe they've changed the pricing
now but like I think when I bought it it
was seven hundred dollars
about 500 bucks for like the the kind of
like the generation three Uber ring they
they've sold like a billion dollars of
uber ring so there's definitely demand
for this product like oh and they're the
cumulative sales is is that high
but you go to Costco there's no Uber
ring and there's no replacement for
ordering I think you could create a
company that just says I'm going to make
a ring like thing for Costco and that's
the entire business plan is just to do
that one thing and if you do that one
thing you'd be more successful than 99
of e-commerce stores you got to think
smarter and not work not not like try to
work so hard so like similarly I would
go in I would hunt down what are the
products that are not yet in Walmart or
Costco places that drive insane volume
Target's another one
um that there is proven kind of like
high-end New York La Lululemon drink it
a little lemon uh Peloton type of
customer that
that that buys a product like that and
you just bring it down market and like
just make it a little worse like they're
a gun and like you know they've done
this with a bunch of them
um and go figure out which one is not
there like for example the mattress
thing it's actually not there yet there
is no eight Sleep mattress there there
is no Uber ring there yet at least last
time I walked around
um and I think that's a just a simple
strategy for e-commerce have you heard
of echelon Echelon no you should look up
Echelon so Echelon is a fitness company
they started uh Peloton it looks exactly
like Valentine I don't know when exactly
they started but they it's it's an
American company I think too so if you
go to Echelon Fitness I think they maybe
have changed their branding but before
it was the same red dude
it was a Peloton but cheaper and they
now yes and they do uh the guy who
started I read this interview with him
so basically they have the uh the mirror
the fitness mirror that was really
popular called Mirror they have a smart
rower which a few companies did and they
did the Peloton bike now they have a
smart treadmill and they just did the
same thing but cheaper and at first it
was all the same branding but instead of
Peloton it said Echelon they're on track
to do 200 million dollars a year in
Revenue this year I think it's a
bootstrap company like I think they just
said like whatever you do so it says uh
Peloton rival Echelon uh Fitness eyes uh
one billion dollar valuation so maybe
they oh they they recently uh raised
some money uh but they
we're like yeah we're just gonna do the
same thing but a little bit cheaper and
we're calling it The Echelon it's pretty
wild that they pulled this off I saw
them originally at CES and I was like oh
cool a Peloton booth and it was Echelon
it was it was the same thing it was the
exact same thing it was pretty funny and
they do they have a ride with pitbull so
like Pitbull the rapper is like the guy
uh that they chose they're in Walmart
Costco Target things like that whereas
you know Lululemon's company Mir and
Peloton was like [__] Walmart people
not a chance like we want skinny people
to get skinnier you know like it was
that was their whole [__] and they went
the exactly like Peloton but the seat is
wider yeah other sorts of people yeah
yeah that's what that's what their motto
is other sorts of people uh and anyway
yeah we are your type yeah we're gonna
make you look like the before picture
instead of the way before picture uh and
so anyway pretty cool that they've done
exactly what you're talking about this
Kevin Hart thing
it's kind of stupid it's kind of cheap
though right
if if I'm if I'm Kevin Hart I don't know
if I would be doing this it's 100
million dollars is gonna be stupid
because that's what he's gonna make off
this thing
I have a meaty topic about your old
company the milk Road and how I think
that you guys have just made a huge
mistake I'm going to bring that up in a
minute and I want to get your opinion on
it but before I do I want to talk about
something that's not business related at
all but it kind of is and I'm gonna get
to it uh I've been working on like
different body stuff like I love like
experimenting with body and this is like
a little uh vein of me to bring this up
but I posted these pictures in our doc
and they're about
two months apart and basically what I've
been experimenting with body wise is
like getting super lean and like
somewhat skinny and then like gaining
weight again but without getting fat you
know they call it like a like a dirty
bulk that's when you eat like a ton of
food and you but you get muscle and you
get fat I've been experimenting with
that
but look at the difference of the two
pictures that I shared and if this is on
YouTube we'll put it on the screen I
guess it seems a little weird but I
guess we'll do it dude we're making this
the thumbnail if you're gonna bring this
up we're getting the click so uh welcome
all of our thumbnail viewers who clicked
because you saw a before and after of
sale well it's not the the pictures
aren't that shocking but here's what
I've been testing just a difference of
two to three hundred calories a day for
two months so you go down to like 1900
to 2000 or 1900 or 2100 ish that's my
window when I'm getting skinny up to
like 23 2400 that's the difference 300
calories a day 200 calories a day that's
the difference that's like a Twinkie or
uh like a pack of M M's that's not a lot
of slices of cheese or something yeah
it's not a significant amount in my case
it's mostly protein so it's a little bit
more protein is that crazy how big of a
difference that can make
it is crazy
um I saw you post that on IG
and I was I was I had a great joke or
something I remember I had a great joke
and then I was like you know I'm not
gonna make this joke this would be
getting wiser I said I'm not gonna make
this joke because some people get real
sensitive about their body and they
don't they don't want jokes uh like even
a funny joke won't come across well so I
said let me just let me just hit the
like button and move on carry on here
but I do have a question just say it
just say it come on I don't even
remember it now it was something about
like you know what you know when a
person's like super fit
then you have to like pull them down
when someone's like fat you have to like
bring them up so I was I was gonna make
funny in some way but you know I don't
remember what it was at this point
um I have a question for you or the
thing that stood out was you were
basically saying this is a 200 calorie
difference
and I was like that's kind of stunning
it's stunning and by the way that's not
precise so I I uh typically weigh stuff
I've been traveling for the last six
weeks so I don't waste stuff but I track
everything so a lot of it's eyeballing
so I could be give or take what are you
tracking everything in my fitness pal so
I use my body tutor and I meet with them
weekly and we go over like the plan and
they give me like the plan to use and
then I have a trainer called Central
athlete and they tell me what workouts
to do and so I just tracked everything
and they review it all
right and so you um what's a typical day
of eating for you right now so right now
I prefer getting a lot of protein early
in the day so I'll do
um roughly 100 grams of protein firstly
fasting are you just doing the like 30
you know 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes like which because I've heard
both schools of thought intermittent
fasting people like I don't fast and
then Tim Ferriss in the four-hour body
was like no no protein right away right
when you wake up I don't fast because it
uh I'm hungry in the morning so I don't
fast so I get up uh around 9 30 I'll
have a cup of yogurt so that's like 15
grams of protein I think uh and then
I'll maybe eat like a banana and then
I'll go and get a really hard workout in
and then afterwards I'll do I use a
Ascent or momentous protein and I do
Four Scoops with just water and I drink
that and then I won't eat till dinner
and then of course a lot right it isn't
it supposed to be like one per thing is
that's like the one or a serving one or
two and so each scoop's like 20 grams 25
25 yeah so you just get 100 grams right
there and that can the body even absorb
that much protein powder at once that's
what I always wondering so I don't know
I I think that the preferred method is
to get that protein from food and
chicken but I just like doing it so I
just like drinking it at one and I feel
really full and then at dinner time I
eat chicken and vegetables and usually
like a dessert
oh wait so there's no lunch
that's my lunch is like the the protein
I I just feel like a banana a thing of
yogurt you'd drink a shitload of protein
powder
and then you later for dinner like we're
talking like 6 p.m now something like
that right yeah yeah I'll eat like 1300
calorie meal
you have a huge dinner of chicken and
veggies and chicken or fish and veggies
and the veggies will be something green
and also like a potato and then I'll
usually do like a like a piece of candy
or ice cream or something like a very
small serving of that like uh last night
I had chocolate covered almonds like 250
calories worth
and that adds up to roughly 20 23 to
2300 23 to 24 yeah
that's crazy I mean that crazy like
that's so different is what I should say
because obviously it works so maybe I'm
crazy for not doing that
um but here's the thing it's like so
little food it's not that much food
sometimes if I have a really hard
workout I'll do a banana and a bagel but
I'll just do a plain bagel like 350
calories of carbs right before I go work
out
um I'm not like I don't know if this is
the right thing to do I think I think
probably the right thing to do is to get
like proper food but I just don't I'm
looking at this photo it looks like the
right thing to do to me right like what
what else what are we measuring here
I I yeah I don't know Instagram likes
that's how you measure your health and
that is working right now so here's the
thing though that I've learned and this
has like changed my confidence in life
and in business and everything learning
how to manipulate your body because like
that's what everyone wants to do is
either get skinnier gain weight like
everyone like wants to do something with
their body once you learn yeah how many
people are happy just like yeah yeah
like everyone wants to improve their
body in some way what I want yes but the
thing is is like what I've learned so
I've been going hard at this I think
like it was two years ago I texted you
and I go I go I'm gonna become an
Instagram Fitness influencer it was a
joke but not entirely a joke but I was
like I want to figure this out and so I
just went and learned how it worked and
once I figured out that it's like a
mathematical equation life became so
much better and I just it was just like
you do this you do this you do this and
you do it for three six 12 months or
whatever you likely are gonna see
results and then what it did was it gave
me so much confidence that it's I
realized wow this is just like business
business is actually the same thing you
do this you do this you do this and the
likelihood of getting some type of
result is high hopefully you'll get your
desired result but you're going to be
better than when you started uh but then
it's like that became the truth for me
it it was as if I had bad eyesight and I
put on glasses like that became the
truth with so many other things you do
this you do this you do this and you
trust the process you hire a coach or
you develop your own plan you follow the
plan and you have to do it for three six
12 months whatever and it's really fun
to start seeing results and then once
particularly with the body I think
emotions would be next but with the body
it's like oh wow I could manipulate
manipulate that and then also with money
we do it with money I can manipulate
money by doing X Y and Z then it becomes
like I can do anything and so right like
once I've conquered the body part it
feels awesome it feels so good
um that's exactly that's so on point um
and by the way the opposite is true
when you want something and you don't
figure out how to bend reality to make
it happen
a little seed of Doubt gets planted in
the brain that's now there that says
you're like man I could do anything I
put my mind to and there's a part of
your head that says really or is it like
that diet
or is it like sleeping early or is it
like you know making money like whatever
the thing that you wanted to do that you
didn't
you didn't actualize you didn't manifest
into reality by by doing it I'll tell
you a little story this is very much
relates to a conversation I had
yesterday with my trainer so
talking to my trainer and I said uh I
wrote a number on the on the mirror I
just went in there I wrote 53. he's like
53 what like what are we doing 53 of
something 53 push-ups what is this I go
about 53 days left because what do you
mean I got oh I had this realization I'm
eight weeks away from having the body I
want
that's 56 56 days where did you start
and where did you you at your Peak you
were like 280 no no no no I'm I'm
basically the same weight I was at the
start you look way different muscle and
fat a little bit but like oh no 220 and
I'm currently like 229 through to 30. so
it's like I actually went up and wait a
little bit but the composition changed a
bit sorry you just looked horrible when
you started now you look awesome so
that's a great compliment actually uh no
you can see you can see her biceps you
look you look significantly different
from when we first started so so I told
her I said I'm I'm am I I'm eight weeks
away from everything I want he's like oh
that's that's great I said uh so I'm
just I'm keeping track right now I'll
just put I'll just keep changing this
number every day that I eat exactly the
way I want this number goes down and uh
if I don't we go back to the beginning
and uh we start I don't know if we go
all the way back or if I'm just gonna
like add three every time I uh if I slip
but I haven't slipped yet so I haven't
had to think about it all right so
anyways we're talking and we have this
philosophy so being my training we have
this philosophy where
um we both are very into mindset and
what's cool is what happened what I had
experienced previously in my life was
I'm really into mindset things I'm
basically like you know in San Francisco
there's that angry Jesus guy who walks
around with a megaphone yeah being like
Jason lives he's alive he's alone that's
like this guy just walks around so much
like in the heart of like where all the
startups are there's one guy that just
walks around like that he's famous
everybody knows him
I was kind of lat with mindset stuff I'd
be like life is what you responds not
how you react right like there is no
meaning except the meaning you're giving
it
your mood is your choice like you know I
was just like walking around like and
nobody really cared and in fact most
people were generally somewhat annoyed
with my uh my ongoing uh conviction in
like the mind the power of the mind and
how important is to master the mind your
wife's like yeah I get it Sean if you
think you can I think you can't you're
probably right I get it just eat your
[__] noodles you can take out the
trash like I told you too you know yeah
that's kind of where she lands
and I'm like but is the trash already
taken out would we really think about it
yeah that annoying guy and so and so
then um I'm sorry I made my I made my
trainer
he's like like he's got his megaphone I
got my megaphone and they touched we
were both into the same things
I've read that book I'm like in the
morning do you sit down and think about
these things he's like I do you're like
more annoyed than like two improv kids
or two vegans take it out exactly we're
truly improv if you can take it out
exactly right yes I am yes I am you're
just constantly like trying to one-up
each other
so so normally that's the thing and we
and to Hype ourselves up we're like dude
it's so nice to talk to another black
belt it's like there's a lot of white
belts want to run around here and you
try to help them out but they don't even
really want to learn the techniques it's
so nice to talk to another black belt
listen you know what's nice about it I
don't even have to say the thing
actually I'll say two words three words
about the subject enough said you
actually already know you've read the
thing you've actually practiced that we
already agree there's no defensiveness
and so we just Implement and what's your
what's your workout that day just back
padding
yeah just like today we're working on
our triceps yeah
so so while we're having this
conversation he's been he's been telling
me this thing he's like he's like bro I
like he's like I like big weights and
thin books and I was like what he's like
I like big weights and thin books
instead we'll crack each other up about
that he likes to lift weights and he's
like I like thin books meaning I like to
just understand the premise of the book
and move on and I appreciate books that
are thin and so what we've always talked
about simple Simplicity how do you
simplify a concept so that you
understand it so that others can
understand things this is something I
always try to do
and we've talked about like what's
simpler than a book a fan book what's
simpler than a thin book you know um a
blog post just simply with a blog post a
tweet what's simpler than a tweet a
little catchphrase what's simpler than a
catch phrase
a gesture and so we had been playing
with this idea of you're doing too much
just do less
we were like there uh this phrase that
I've been saying on the Pod and and off
the bottom the the season I'm in right
now is the season of intensity is the
strategy so
uh for me that applies very easily with
the with the body a diet thing it's like
I don't need a new strategy I don't need
a different workout program I don't need
a new coach I don't need a new uh diet I
don't need a new anything I don't need
to go get a new app to track it all I
simply need to do is execute the very
simple plan
with much higher intensity and so I just
had this little thing where I just
just this just if you're on YouTube you
see this I'm just turning the knob up
the dial and just turn the dial and now
what I'm working on sometimes he'll just
he'll just go hold on
he'll just turn up the dial that just I
know what that means I know exactly what
I need to do I need to multiply the
intensity I'm bringing to the current
situation I'm doing the same thing
whether it's on food or whatever just
this is all I need to do everything I
want is on the other side of this little
gesture all right cool it looks like
you're rubbing a nipple your neighbors
are just like why is this guy doing like
a necessary he's like be careful with
that one and I said well I only hear
there's two possible good
interpretations of this and so um
so the reason I'm coming from soccer
Hill coming full circle to the thing you
said which is what I told him I said
look
I want to he's like you know you got to
know your why I said I know my why my
why is because I know that if I could do
this
now there is an Unstoppable feeling that
comes from knowing that you put your
mind to something and you did it I said
I don't really care I'm already married
I got two kids I don't need to walk on a
beach and like be attractive that's not
a thing for me what I do care about is I
can't have there be an area of my life
that I wanted something in and not have
that reality to my will like I can't not
have done that right and so once I have
done that it's just yet another yet
another area of my life that I was able
to to do that just dial up the intensity
and get the result and that creates the
Unstoppable confidence
um it furthers the confidence to the
point of being Unstoppable because this
is the only area of my life I haven't
yet done that and so
um I highly recommend for anybody the
area where you have struggled that's the
that's the place to put the emphasis
that's the place to try to overcome not
even for the thing but because you want
to be the type of person who could do
that thing that's at least what's worked
for me so far and why I have a lot more
momentum than I had in the past because
in the past I was like I really care if
I have abs like I'm not sure that that
matters to me no you definitely care but
it feels good I read the stupid article
on Vice and it was like gyms are built
for skinny people and I can't go to the
gym because I'm fat and people stare at
me and I thought and this is for anyone
listening who's fat right now or out of
shape go to the gym you want to know why
when I have never been to a gym and seen
a that person and thought that person's
gross I've only thought dude that's sick
they're they're getting after it they're
trying in fact I get inspiration when I
see someone overweight because I'm like
damn the first step's the hardest
they're actually in a harder spot than I
am so if you're listening to this
[__] go get fit it feels so good to
like achieve a goal and to make progress
it feels awesome and so I've learned a
lot over these past few years like
getting my stuff together and it feels
amazing I I I've enjoyed this
tremendously so I wanted to bring that
up really quick and what's cool is like
once you like basically if you're like
out of shape and fat
you only need to do like like for
example if I if Sean you were like I
just want to get strong I'll be like
well just do this this and this it's
really simple uh like do five reps five
sets of this this and this it's quite
simple and then eat this much food and
then once you get like down to that like
80th or 90th percentile of Fitness then
it's like all right we're gonna do
really small adjust adjustments and
you're gonna see like bigger changes so
it's really fun to like see like all
right I just need to like get to this
point and that's easy and I'm gonna do a
general plan that works for everyone and
then as you get fitter it's like oh
you're just gonna dial this a little bit
dial this a little bit and that's really
cool to like see those little small
changes 300 calories a day what that
what does that mean or eating a bagel
instead of a banana for your before your
workout does that change anything it's
like these little small things it's been
really fun to like see how that works
and I think maybe just because I get
older and my body doesn't respond the
same so it's like these things actually
matter but if you're listening to this
that's what you have to look forward to
if you're out of shape if you're already
in shape it's really fun to test those
small dials yeah
I have one topic Sean so yeah last week
or this week maybe milk Road your old
company so Sean started a company called
milk Road it was an email newsletter
that was a daily news newsletter for
crypto enthusiasts it was awesome still
is awesome you guys you sold it and so
it's not you or I don't actually know
what your involvement is but you
launched this thing called milk Road Pro
I believe so the launch for it was cool
it happened
um I actually don't see the date but I'm
looking at like the newsletter when you
launched it and it's like 300 a year or
20 a month or sorry ten no it was ten
dollars a month ten dollars a month and
150 a year whatever and what you get is
you get um Market insights and deep
dives from milk roads research team
weekly Recaps on everything happening in
the space uh quarterly funding
breakdowns cool awesome first before I
give my criticism I think it's sick that
you guys tried this second do you know
if it's working
um I know a little bit so I wasn't
involved in the launch of this or the
um the details like what it is the price
all that stuff so I wasn't really
involved in that I knew they were going
to do it
um and I was like cool cool idea to try
let's do it and um
that's all I know about that part I
don't know the results of it just so far
so if I've been in this situation so I
had the hustle I launched a 300 a year
thing the biggest mistake I made or a
big mistake I made was instead of
charging 300 a year I should have made
something that I could have charged
thirty thousand dollars a year yeah and
dropped to zero you oh you dropped a
zero over here you wanna come get that
yeah I dropped I I dropped two of them
two zeros and the difference between
those two price points is it it it's a
ton but I actually don't think that the
work is as big as a difference in price
points or at least the F the at least
the effort that goes into that and can I
give you a few examples of what I would
have done instead if I was the milk Road
the first thing I and by the way I'm in
the back seat here I don't know anything
they probably I'm sure maybe they
thought about this and there's reasons
why and there's probably some strategy
so this is totally a guy who doesn't
know anything about the strategy the
first thing I would have done or these
are all different ideas of what could
have worked I would have researched the
first thing tell me what you think about
this not a crypto job board that's that
stinks been there done that I would have
done a crypto job uh crypto salary
benchmarking meaning as any user that
signs up I would have asked them where
they were what their job title is and
how much money they made and then I
would have took like what the benchmarks
is what the Benchmark is for different
salaries and I would have packaged that
and try to see if I can sell that to HR
departments at crypto companies which I
don't know if they're actually hiring a
lot right now so I'd have to do more
research but I think I would have done
something like that there's a few
companies that have done this there's
salary.com and there's pay scale I think
pay scale does something like two or
three hundred million dollars a year in
subscription Revenue when they sell into
this uh what's your what's your gut
Instinct on that one and you're saying
instead of milk or you're saying this is
a part of it
instead of these are these are things I
would have done instead of what what I
think that's a cool idea
um I think you know the crypto the
number of crypto companies that are
mature enough to care about salary
things I think is a little
early for that I feel like something
like that's going to work in a few years
not not well now's a good time to start
then man right yeah fair enough
um and then so when I'm thinking about
these new ideas I would think most of my
ideas for what you guys should have
launched are data related the reason I
like data is a I actually think that's
within the core competency of a company
creating newsletters I think creating a
software platform would have been a
horrible idea because that's not within
your core core competency I also would
have looked at what data can I get from
my users and what are they clicking on
in order to like track different data
and if possible I would have tried to
make something that my advertisers would
also want to buy but that's actually
quite hard and that that last one I
don't think I could have done the second
thing I would have looked at is
sentiment analysis again totally I'm a
total Outsider here so but I wonder if
big Banks or big buyers of crypto stuff
if they would care what does the little
guy think like the retail investor and
what I would have done is and I think
there's a few I think there's it's
called San
they do like four or five billion
dollars a year in revenue and what they
do is they look at Behavior analytics of
like different crypto markets and how it
works I think there's augmento there's a
few more that like look at this but I
would have like seen because the thing
with crypto is it seems like a lot of
stuff happens in Discord and if anything
happens at Discord a gray hair guy is
not going to be able to figure that out
right yes true and so I'm wondering
definitely true could could milk Road
have figured out
what the little guy is talking about
before it kind of pops and gets
sentiment analysis packaged in a more
professional way than Discord what do
you think about that
I think that's a good idea I think
there's um so we've been doing this
thing called the fear and greed index
from the beginning which I love which is
basically a uh it's a meter that just
shows what's the Market's mood it isn't
kind of like based on the uh like from
the stock market this has been the case
for a long time which is
um you know the market is very moody it
gets extremely fearful it gets extremely
greedy and you kind of want to be buying
when it's fearful and you want to be
selling when it's greedy if you wanted
to time it or at least it does not buy
when the market is feeling super greedy
um uh but like it's good to know where
where the sentiment stands because you
could sort of price is very very linked
to that
and at the beginning we didn't have any
first party data so we used an existing
fear and green index and we just skinned
it and designed it to fit our brand
but I'm pretty sure now we have probably
the biggest ability of anybody to pull
for that exactly um outside of a
coinbase or others could do it but
they're not they're not doing it but in
terms of media like we're one of the
biggest I think we are the biggest
newsletter for crypto so I think and we
get a lot of feedback like if we say hey
tell us acts they'll like we'll get tons
of responses uh for every email and so I
think that we could have basically built
our own fear and greed index or built
that out like maybe per coin or per
project per nft like what is the
sentiment around this what are the
whales saying so like just create a
cohort of whales and their sentiment
that take that data and package it up
for any of the financial like
institutional money that's in this space
um so I do think that that that has a
possibility and that is a 30 000 product
not a not a a 10 a month product and
then what I would have done is like
looked at that analysis and the data and
then also had my researchers and writers
give context around this and to explain
their sources and why they think it
means what it means and I think because
the research they do in this Pro thing
is actually good and the problem is when
it's gonna be super low priced I think
that it's really hard to go that extra
mile
on any one topic and because you know
the the by the reader may not even be
that sophisticated or have that much
skin in the game and then the writer has
to turn out lots of content for a wider
base but if you know hey this is a
narrow group of people that really care
a lot about these specific things you
could go be the best in the world at
delivering that type of Intel and you
host conferences and a handful of other
things around that and that is a thirty
thousand dollar a year product I think
now yeah packaging all of that is
challenging and pulling it off is
challenging but I don't think it's like
significantly more challenging than the
work that they already have to do it's
just packaged differently and the last
two things that was the sales work is
different so in this the sales work is
easy you put a link in the newsletter
today and you say hey you want to read
this section go check out Pro Sales work
is easy content work is is about the
same
um but the value obviously of the sale
is what matters so the other case you
have to basically
go and meet with
head of research at some some firm some
blockchain investing firm or some
traditional uh you know hedge fund or
whatever and you have to basically do an
Enterprise sale to get them on board
correct the differences and this is an
advantage is that milk road is small and
your burn is small so you only a couple
deals two sales yeah maybe it could make
a meaningful difference and you just
start you start small and you start slow
and I think that I could pull off you're
not a VC find a company that has to grow
and support you know a million dollar a
month team the last two things something
that has always interested me is
organizational charts which sounds
boring but with crypto well this is
combined with two ideas but with crypto
you don't always know who's behind stuff
because
you uh like a lot of it's just like
someone's face that's a nft or something
like that and you're not exactly sure
who's behind it uh what I would do is I
would have done org charts that explains
here's who's behind each thing here's
the team here's their contact
information and here's the story behind
it as well as our prediction of like is
this like interesting or not interesting
should you trust it because if you're if
a bank or or a buyer or a funder of some
of these companies wants to know like
what's the real deal behind them it's
really challenging to get a surface
level or even a more than surface level
view on it without doing lots of your
own research so if you have data that
can actually pinpoint
uh this is actually legitimate it's
worth diving deeper into and here's some
more analysis on that or this one just
is nonsense run like something like that
and your customer being either a someone
who wants to sell into those companies
or someone who wants to fund invest or
purchase something from them it kind of
gives you a little bit more quantitative
and qualitative information on are they
worth the time do you know what I mean
yeah yeah I know what you mean
um that one's I I like that one I like
that one less than the other ones so I
think these are all good ideas I like
the theme of these data driven uh like
basically once you acquire this Corpus
of data it just simply becomes more
valuable over time it has to be updated
and refreshed but it's not like new it's
not new content in the same way it's
building a stack of content
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
I was talking to or I was reading this
post about Zoom info do you know what
Zoom info is
yeah it's basically just like here's
everyone's email address is that the
like dummy version of it yeah they're
publicly traded though they do like a
billion dollars in Revenue I don't know
what their market cap is they're big but
it's what do they provide beyond that
it's basically like it's for sales
people right like hey sales person
here's how you do your prospecting I
think the high level view is basically
we have mapped out every employee at
every company in America and we know
like what they do we know their contact
information and we know a little bit of
background about the company
um right and the way that they started
it was the two Founders they said we
spent 75 percent of our time just
calling the front desk of all these
companies to confirm that their phone
number was correct and that was how it
started then we went and got a bunch of
different data sources and we combined
them to make it a little bit more
readable so you could have more data on
different companies and then finally
they created a I don't know what you
call it like a viral Loop whatever it's
called where people could access some of
the data but they had to submit their
own data and so in order to get a
discounted price and that kind of
created this Loop where now they have so
much information on different companies
how they work if you Google like a
company and then Revenue you might find
Zoom info that will show up but it will
say like their contact information where
their office is and things like that
and so they started just by the two guys
just phone calling and so these
companies data businesses can be cool
because you can brute force your way to
get like a nice little MVP so anyway
that's my my Spiel on milk Road I I
think that I don't know the background
of what the owners are doing so I could
be totally off that's what I would have
done instead though
so here's a um tool that's pretty cool
that's uh related have you ever heard of
particle.com no I'm gonna go to it now
though so particle just without the e so
it's
p-a-r-t-i-c-l.com unlock the power of
driven product development uh yeah what
it should say is see how much any
Ecommerce store does in sales because
that's what it does
right that's like the layman's term like
again Zoom info's like hey you want to
sell [__] uh we'll tell you who to reach
out to and here's their email address
right like they have to sort of mask it
and make it sound a little fancier than
it is but it's very functional very
useful and similarly particle is pretty
cool so what they did is
um for pretty much uh all the major
e-commerce Stores
um
they what they did is they they have a
way to go to any like kind of Shopify
store and estimate with
fairly high confidence and it's not
perfect but it's directionally correct
um
what that store does in sales within
that what each what which SKU they uh
they sell like uh you know what's the
top selling top selling products bottom
selling products that sort of thing and
so you could do really great competitive
research and market research to try to
figure out where are there gaps at the
market oh okay this company's doing
really well but there's not a lot of
competitors that also sell that product
there may be an opportunity to go in
there or hey um you know we're doing
really well with these three products
but our competitor they have this other
product line that we don't have that's
doing really well and so it's a cool
thing that they built um using basically
like seems like crawlers and scrapers to
go onto an e-commerce store and sort of
estimate the um
the volume of uh of sales for product is
not perfect it's like you know because I
I looked at it for like our brand and a
couple other brands of people I know and
so you know the sale the exact sales
number like if it says 50 million they
might do actually 70 million or 60
million right it's just directionally
it's directional it's like it's not 500
that they do probably
um but and it's not five it's more like
50 it's more like 50. and uh but the
product level stuff seems to be more
accurate
um where you know again relatively like
product a is more popular product B by
by double right no okay interesting what
what is that what can we learn from that
how do we and they sell this thing for
like I don't know 20 grand a year
um to your point because if I'm a
retailer and I can be smarter about my
inventory purchases
um
I'll bake back the 20 grand and you know
one or two purchases just by just by by
having this in intel if I didn't have it
earlier so it kind of makes sense how
these companies are able to charge so
much is this company big particle
yeah I think they're pretty big
um I don't know too much you know you
can't search them on the platform
unfortunately but uh it seems like there
seems like they're doing pretty well
who's the owner of milk road now what
are their names again Mike uh Kendall
and Mike Kendall and Mike
uh Bravo launching us on this clip they
don't listen to podcasts they don't
listen to any podcasts
um and so uh like in fact when we first
met him I was like yeah seconds podcast
blah blah and then uh he's just like
wasn't really that interested in the
podcast and I was like do you listen to
our pod any pod you listen to podcast
he's like no why would I really
understand why would I do that like um
he was just like I just feel like I
should just work instead of listening to
other people talk about work okay oh
well
touche
absolutely right that is what a
successful person would say
if you guys are listening that's what I
would have done this is what I learned
from launching my product on I mean we
were Trends were successful but I
realized we could have had two zeros at
the end of our Revenue probably if we
would have done things differently yeah
good feedback I like it um what else you
got
um okay well that was amazing let's just
first start with that great idea next
um you know with a guy with three ideas
they're getting those uh backpacking uh
reps in nice yeah yeah can't stop won't
stop never quit no days off
you said backpacking that's what I'm
gonna do because I'm a nice guy so with
ideas like this I think I should be in
the tech All-Star Game what's the tech
All-Star Game you asked it's something I
wish existed so I tweeted this out
and um I think that I laid out my case
for why the tech industry needs its
version of the NBA All-Star Game so Tech
is getting pretty big in fact somebody
pointed that somebody who's not in the
tech industry pointed this out to me
they go yes weird
I feel like Tech is the new [__]
everyone in Hollywood's like talking
about he's like you know like the
Facebook movie was dope he's like and
then they came out with silica Valley
HBO and they have like you know they
have the Wii the wework movie they got
the theranos movies they got the Uber
story they got the like it's making its
way more into pop culture and what
happens when something gets in the
movies is those Heroes become Heroes so
the the protagonists in these in these
things becomes like a new
archetype that people want to follow and
so he was pointing this out he's like I
think Tech has just crossed over into
this thing where the cool tech people
are now popular everywhere you see this
with Elon Musk Mark Zuckerberg they're
like how they're household names now
Jeff Bezos whereas you know I couldn't
have told you who the CEO of IBM was
growing up like I had no idea but it's
that that's changed now so he's like you
still can't name the CEO of IBM
like I used to not be able to name who
the CEO of IBM was I still I still can't
but I at least want to know I definitely
used to not be able to
so I think somebody should create this I
think somebody should create
um
a weekend event that's produced like a
like the NBA All-Star weekend and get
the best talent in the tech industry to
compete so here's how I think you see
that you're gonna have like a uh like a
like the layup contest or like the base
the base hit Derby no no no it's gonna
be a hackathon real soon so it's a
hackathon that's the main that's the
main attraction that's the that's the
game is a hackathon and what we'll do is
each so you get you only get invited if
you're like a legit awesome tech company
so you go from like the top like okay
Facebook you get to send a team or maybe
a couple teams and but so does I don't
know figma you guys have made it
congratulations you get to participate
in the thing and so the CEO of each
company gets to recruit one engineer
one designer and one marketer for their
squad they get to come and they're going
to compete in the weekend hackathon they
got to build something awesome and they
have to pitch it at the end and you get
to kind of see these people actually
like watch them cook a little bit like
let me see you actually do work like are
you creative are you interesting can you
build something cool
um can you sell can you pitch I want to
see see that in action I think it would
be a phenomenal recruiting event for
companies I think it would be just a
great like kind of brand Builder I think
it'd be fun for these people because Mo
I don't know most tech CEOs jobs are
actually like just dealing with problems
and not even the fun types it's not even
like product problems it's like people
problems and lawsuit problems and and
[__] like that so I think it'd be a nice
diversion for people who got into this
because they like to build [__] and that
this is how they actually started their
company and I think that you the way
that Elon and soccer started competing
now I think it's going to open the door
to more direct competition friendly
competition amongst tech people and then
I think you do the fun gimmick games
right you have the whatever the the
speed typing contest or you have who can
do X while they're drunk whatever you
come up with like some random ass games
for other people to try as well you
broadcast the whole thing
and I think that like you could kind of
if you had the right like if I'm I was
trying to think who has the incentive to
do this so none of the companies have
the incentive to do this only somebody
who's just like stupid like me has the
incentive to do this where I'm like yeah
this one I'm gonna spend my time on for
the year and like I don't need money so
I can just like do this and like I think
the whole thing it would be profitable
because you could get sponsors for the
whole thing and um I think either me or
somebody like um
Eric tornberg I thought would be great
at this because he's got a lot of great
connections and he
he comes from the Sports World so he
like appreciates that part of it and
sees that it's missing here I also think
that VC funds like sort of like
interested Horowitz or whoever could use
this as an excuse to create like a
festival or a fair that's different than
a traditional boring conference so
nobody's gonna do this but I think this
would be a fun idea I wish this existed
what's your reaction do you remember the
Silicon Valley Sports League
listen no what is that it was awesome it
was like a wreck Sports league and um we
did soccer one season another season it
was flag football and it was awesome it
was basically different companies would
pay 10 grand per season and you could
have 10 players play and it was like a
really fun way to like hang out and uh
you know get to know your team and like
play sports and it would at the time I
was at apartment list it was like
apartment list versus I forget whatever
company was like nearby and you like it
was awesome it was really yeah it was
really fun and the guys who started it
used the profits to bootstrap their
company
and it was sick and they said they made
millions of dollars from it you've not
heard of that no but I'm on their
website right now I don't know if you've
been there in a while no look at this
Banner image this might be the worst
Banner image I've ever seen it's two
evil looking Tech Guys
pretending to play football against each
other the guys holding the football not
like how you would hold a football when
you run first of all tiny hands and
can't hold a football and the other guy
looks like an absolute hyena that's
actually coming to take your data and
sell it and not like play sports at all
this is
if the artist who did this hates the
tech industry they like lost their their
two-bedroom Loft in San Francisco
because they raised the rent so that
like some tech bro could live there and
now he's on the street doing art like
this you just have to make it boxing
though you got to get you got to get to
the you got to get to the boxing I mean
the YouTubers are doing it now but
people aren't going to do the boxing
thing like even
like best case scenario is this Elon
Zuckerberg thing it's also not even
gonna happen it's not gonna happen they
have too much to lose and it's too hard
to be good at boxing you've seen this
with the YouTuber thing Jake Paul
actually like dropped out of life and
has been like trains boxing for years
to look Okay and like imagine a tech an
interesting Tech person is like in their
40s or 50s typically
or they're like the scrottiest 25 year
old that like like spent their whole
life building the thing and not working
out like I just don't think it's gonna
look okay I think it's gonna look really
bad and sad when you watch it why don't
you just do this
what's holding you back I mean it's fun
yeah it seems fun but I think it's a you
know it's a fun idea that if I knew that
I could get the right people involved
maybe but you need the ape you need the
a players to do this I'm not interested
in apartment lists head of growth versus
uh you know feed finders you know
customer success guy like you know we're
not doing that it needs to be Zuck and
his team Elon and his team and then like
you know like it needs to be like top
people doing this like the Airbnb
founder like that's who people would
want to tune in because you don't get to
meet these people you definitely don't
get to see them work you only see them
getting rehearsed interviews about how
they started something 10 years ago or
like why they're not ruining the world
right now like that's the only thing
that's only context we see these people
in you don't really get to see them in a
context that makes them likable
favorable and like you know admirable
are you on a roll right now should we
just let you rattle these off I have
three like alliterations there pretty
much so yeah I thought the feet together
feet finder was a gem too I was just
like that was on my list as an idea but
I haven't researched it somebody just
told me feed finder crushes it and I go
what is feed finder and they go I think
it's only finder for feet and I said
bookmark that we'll look more at that
later is that really a Thing If you find
her oh my God you're right it is yeah
the safest place the safest largest
easiest website to view buy and sell
feet content
great yeah oh my god dude this is wild
Paige you're right they do killer oh wow
yeah that's some home page they get four
million uh yeah we'll save this for
another time oh my God that is a home
page uh don't go to facebook.com if
you're with your family uh all right let
me give you another quick one so
related to my only fans and now feed
finder uh curiosity Okay so
Ben sent me a uh link to something
called onlypage.com and page as in like
the girl's name page and I thought this
is kind of interesting so I go to it and
it's basically only fans so there's some
model named Paige and she's like hey
subscribe to me and you get my content
and you get all the same things as only
fans but she was hosting it's that
golfer the what I don't know what's her
full name
is she a famous athlete I have no idea I
think she started as like a mediocre a
mediocre coffee but she's a golfer but
she's really good looking and so now
she's in the news and stuff all the time
for just being like this hot athlete her
name is Paige S I forget her last name
but something like that I mean the
variety of content here you scroll down
it's golf instruction and it says
warming up and she's just bending over
on a putting green it says the mental
game and she's talking about that and
then there's just bra tutorial
I don't know how many guys are
subscribing to watch a broad tutorial
for that you know that the the bra
techniques but you know this is a
she knows what she's doing let me just
put it this way I sent you her Wikipedia
it's Paige spiranac uh so I guess she
was a former professional golf player
she was a division one golfer and then
she just got famous for being pretty
good at golf and then people were like
you're very attractive and she was like
I guess I should I I should lean into
that one she's talking to her Mentor
she's like I'm I'm pretty good at golf
but I'm amazing at boobs like what if I
should go with this and they're like you
know what you should you should focus on
your strengths and and so anyways what I
thought was interesting about this is
this is basically a direct consumer
version of only fans it's what Shopify
did so like you before Shopify it's like
you could list your your products on
somebody else's Marketplace Amazon
Walmart whatever
um so that's like one alternative you
could be an Amazon Seller you put your
product on Amazon Amazon is the
storefront people go to Amazon they find
your product that's how only fans Works
people go to go to your only fans it's
hosted on only fans only fans is the
tech platform where you make your
purchases through this is interesting
somebody must have created for there
must be some company behind this
um
or she built this herself which is a
shot like a Shopify version of only fan
she has her own branded domain her own
store and she's handling her own
customer relationship with customers so
when they like for example when you sign
up to somebody's only fans you don't get
their email address
um if they turned you could never Market
back to them that way but with this
theoretically she could and so I thought
that's kind of interesting I wonder like
Shopify turned out to be a very big deal
in the like kind of like Commerce
landscape
clearly only fans the niche is doing you
know billions of dollars a year as a
product like I don't know I don't know
what you would call a category
um Can somebody create the Shopify for
that that's kind of interesting to me
um so I don't know I don't know
the company behind uh her page it's
called you screen so uscreen.tv the
letter U and then screen dot TV and it's
the all-in-one membership platform for
creators to light your Die Hard fans
with exclusive video content in a
Vibrant Community across your own mobile
app and website and on their home page
they list like some YouTuber with two
million subscribers they lived they list
a yoga company kids are is that what it
is there's kids are there's yoga there's
like some German guy there's like a
pregnancy blog
[Laughter]
she's like they're big she's definitely
best selling yeah so she's so it's a
company that's doing it and it looks
like she just found like a course
creator company and was like or a
Porsche platform yeah yeah yeah she's
like yeah we're gonna do that we're
gonna go ahead and just only pay 300 a
month uh this is interesting their thing
says 150 million earned by creators each
year
that's pretty interesting that's uh
that's not like a small number they say
they have nine million end users so like
members on the other side of the the
content yeah and so I never heard of
this have you ever heard of this no I've
never heard of it and it looks like
they're killing it because they just
made maybe some policy changes that
would not allow like kajabi or something
to like uh appeal to that type of
creator
but it's smart so if you click their
leadership team they have a big team
it's a it must be a big company they
have got a huge team it looks like they
have a
50 to 150 employees so it must be
working and if you look them up you
can't find any funding information about
them the company might be killing it and
we just dude I want to make a Chrome
extension that's just called the honesty
filter and it just changes the website
homepage to like say what it actually
does like uh you know like they should
just say monetize your body yeah with
less fees than only fans yeah
and like you know the the zoom info get
people's email address and spam them
like you know these are like what these
companies actually do but if you go like
if I go to zoom info what does it say so
the guy who started it his name's PJ it
looks like he on his LinkedIn he says
they're north of 20 million in an ARR
they're bootstrapped and it's based out
of Washington DC this is a legit company
and before that he had a web hosting
so uh anyway this guy this thing is
bootstrapped is that what you said yeah
that's what his LinkedIn says yeah so
they're probably doing they probably
take like I want to say five to ten
percent of this so maybe something like
10 to 15 million a year in uh in revenue
for them yeah and he says that he's
killing it it says in his LinkedIn it's
over 20 million in ARR it says fast
growing and profitable bootstrap SAS
business revolutionizing the way that
video based entrepreneurs make men get
off
as it says
so yeah PJ I thought you got to turn the
Chrome extension off oh yeah we got you
there
so kudos to PJ like Chrome extension is
called true that and you can find it in
the Chrome Store
that's a side hustle uh good job PJ at
unscreen I don't see Paige on their home
screen I don't know why I wouldn't see
that she's it has four million followers
on Instagram you got a guy on here with
in the front page with 1.8 on on YouTube
we got to put Paige on there but that's
what she's using so her name's Paige
Sarah Nick or something like well maybe
with your new uh body
I don't know maybe you screen ice cream
we all scream for Samsung you know what
I'm saying yeah and uh Paige what's up
uh that's a joke my wife who's listening
that's a joke uh
but I do see that Paige is recently
divorced according to a Wikipedia uh no
I'm just joking she's like a nine I'm a
four that won't ever work out unless and
we could figure out a way um yeah on
screen or you screen whatever it is good
job kudos to you guys they're taking the
business of people who don't want to uh
deal with these people I don't know why
more people don't do this I guess you
have to have a really big uh I mean you
need a big audience Pages four million
uh Instagram followers but does only
fans even drive audience do they drive a
significant amount no they don't they
intentionally don't drive Discovery so
it's kind of like Shopify anyways you
promote yourself they're your storefront
but the thing is it'd be like if every
Shopify store
was on was called shopify.com
store name and if you couldn't collect
your you know the the the emails or
phone numbers of your customers so you
couldn't like you know sell more
products to them or whatever it's all
done through their through their
platform yeah and you screen advertises
that they have like a community platform
I don't think I want to be part of that
Community but just the paywall part
might be worth it so if you're a Creator
I'd be like yeah I'll accept their money
but I don't want to like
you know I don't want to like talk to
them on a regular basis that'd be weird
um yeah that's a good find
Where Do We Go From Here I think that's
it I think we wrap it up all right well
that's their line by the way uh really
quick uh that's the pod that's the Pod I
know I I wanted to tell you something
really quick
um I just got a text while we were
recording from Jason yanowitz at block
work singles
today I got asked to leave the bank
because I was laughing so hard at the at
Sean's Taco Bell story they were like
sir could you please leave your call
outside because I had headphones in it
was laughing so loud so so loud uh I
said yeah yeah no you need to listen to
this podcast and they were like sir what
are you talking about
uh
Well story everyone just taking off his
airpods and played it out loud for the
entire Bank to here it's like oh you got
to hear the story that shot tell us
about making eye contact with the guy
who's farting at a Taco Bell
uh and can I please deposit 500 uh no
apparently that was a hit a lot of
people like that Taco Bell story
congratulations you should uh do more
uncomfortable things I um I went and
replied to a bunch of the comments on
YouTube
um if it comes from the the channel name
that's me
um so I wouldn't reply to a bunch of
them because I had said like we read and
reply to every comment I know people got
mad at you we read all the comments now
there's a lot like there's 700 comments
per episode which
is a lot to reply to I did it for one
and I was like okay I can't go do that
for the next one so I think it's going
to be kind of like I reply to I read all
of them and reply to I don't know a
hundred each time uh because it's it's
now getting I read all of them I read
all of them and a lot of them they got
mad at us for uh being they called us
all a bunch of cucks for liking Zuck
they said you're zucks [__] yeah [__]
Army what's up
we have tattoos on the inside of our
wrist dude isn't it crazy that whenever
whatever whatever sucks working out that
Zuck is now on the liberal side of this
stuff somehow we're like you know left
of center because we like Zuckerberg
that's so funny that he's Fawn like on
that side of this argument uh yeah yeah
but yeah I don't get it they got mad at
us but anyway that's the Pod we'll read
all the comments that's the part
[Music]
thank you